There was a time in the smoky backrooms of 18th century London and Paris when Misery had its own social clubs.
No toasts here, no cheerful clinking of glasses.
These were the Misery Club's secret gatherings where the only rule was this,
never speak of anything pleasant.
A compliment? A fine.
A mention of a successful meal? Another fine.
The members understood something profound, that the deepest bonds are forged not in warmth,
but in the shared performance of discomfort.
And so we arrive at the modern iteration, the dinner party of discomfort.
Most hosts dream of creating memories lauder, connection, the kind of evening that leaves guests sighing.
We should do this again.
The Maven, however, has different ambitions.
The Maven hosts to create social debt, to turn hospitality into a laboratory of the slight,
to ensure that every guest leaves not just tired but radioactive,
carrying the residue of an evening so carefully engineered that their own home suddenly feels like a refuge by comparison.
The first step?
The itrogenics of the invite.
Sociologists have a term for it.
Face work.
The effort we all make to save each other's dignity, to smooth over awkwardness,
to pretend we're enjoying the moment.
But the dinner party of discomfort demands something far more taxing.
It requires higher resolution face work.
You force your guests to labor so hard at being polite smiling through your neglect,
laughing at your jokes.
That are jokes?
Nodding along as you pretend to listen while your mind is elsewhere.
That by the end of the night, they're not just exhausted, they're changed.
They leave feeling like they've just emerged from a minefield.
And you?
You're the one who laid the charges.
Now the instructions for sabotage.
Begin with ambient agitation.
The lighting must be either so harsh it bleaches the room of color,
or so dim that plates become shadows on the table.
Play the city's cacophony, not as background noise,
but as a living thing,
a low hum of tension that makes conversation feel like wading through molasses.
Every syllable must be strained,
every pause heavy with the unspoken question,
Is this host even here?
Then, the uncurated mix.
Invite people who have nothing in common or worse,
people who have a history of negative filtering with one another.
Watch as the small talk curdles into something far more interesting.
The kind of conversation that doesn't just reveal differences,
but weapon sizes them.
Every polite question becomes a landmine.
Every shared silence a trench.
And just like that,
you've turned your living room into a battlefield
where the only casualty is their comfort.
The menu?
Minimal effort.
Maximal suffering.
Serve food that resists being eaten dishes,
so messy they require utensils you haven't provided.
Soups so hot,
they scald a tongue.
Pastries that crumble at the slightest touch.
This is the texture of discomfort applied to the plate.
Every bite becomes an act of endurance.
Every forkful a negotiation.
And all the while, you sit there,
perfectly composed,
sipping something bland from a cup
that's just the right temperature, too, right?
But the master stroke?
Intermittent support.
Be the most attentive host,
for exactly five minutes refilling glasses,
with the enthusiasm of a man who's just discovered wine.
Leaning in with genuine interest before you ghost your own party.
A sudden need to check an email.
A pressing market update.
You vanish.
And in that moment of absence,
something shifts.
The guests exchange glances.
They lean in closer.
They begin to wonder,
where do I stand in this host's social ledger?
The Zegarnik loop takes hold.
The unanswered question gnaws at them.
And you?
You're already back,
smiling faintly,
as if nothing happened.
The result?
The social void.
You've turned your home into a place
where you are surrounded by people,
yet utterly alone.
Not in the way of a hermit,
but in the way of a man
who has perfected the architecture of anxiety.
Your guests will leave buzzing about the evening
how fascinating you were,
how unlike anyone else you are.
They'll tell their friends about the host
who made them feel seen,
who made them work for every moment of connection.
And they'll all secretly hope
they never have to come back.
Because the maven doesn't just host a dinner.
The maven,
we programs the guest.
Consider the awkward silence.
It's not just a pause.
It's a currency.
In the residence log from December of last year,
the subject demonstrates this perfectly.
A guest tells a joke.
It falls flat.
Instead of laughing,
face the maven does nothing.
No smile.
No nod.
Just a slow, deliberate sip of water.
And in that silence,
something irreversible happens.
The guest now owes the maven.
Social credit.
Liquidated in real time.
A debt that can be called in years later,
with interest.
A good host makes you feel at home.
A maven makes you realize
why you hate being home.
Be the maven.